une soirée s'affrontaient ni d'émeutes à
clichy sous bois après la mort de deux
jeunes garçons électrocutés dans un
transformateur edf où ils s'étaient
cachés
la police ne poursuivait pas ces jeunes
selon le ministère de l'intérieur mais
elle était intervenue plus tôt lors
d'une tentative de cambriolage
les prix du gaz vont augmenter c'est sûr
mais le plus fort de la hausse n'aura
lieu qu'après les froids en avril
cet hiver le prix du gaz ne devraient
pas augmenter de plus de 6% pour le
sixième mois consécutif le chômage
recule en france en vo résultat dû
essentiellement au traitement social
mais aussi à la mise en place des
nouveaux contrats bordeleau pour ce long
week-end de la toussaint pour les
saisons d'armes rivon ceux déployés un
peu partout il faut dire que c'est
traditionnellement une période de gros
trafic et donc de nombreux accidents
il s'appelle rafael à 30 ans est déjà
une valeur sûre de la chanson française
et la coqueluche des jeunes filles il
est pendant trois jours à l'olympia
voilà monsieur bonsoir flambée de
violence est né à clichy sous bois après
la mort de deux jeunes adolescentes qui
est inconscient du danger s'était caché
dans un transformateur edf
ils ont été électrocutés un troisième
jeune grièvement brûlé a été
hospitalisée six trois jeunes faisait
semble-t-il partie d'une bande
soupçonnées de cambriolages et de
dégradations dès l'annoncé de leur mort
les jeunes du quartier du chêne pointu
sont descendus dans les rues pour tout
casser
milan 23 voitures brûlées l'école la
poste la mairie saccagé reportage
stéphane breitner avec frange enzo et
grégory vasseur cet après midi les
policiers ont refait leur apparition
dans la ville à pied ou en voiture ils
kadri clichy sous bois pour prévenir le
moindre débordement un peu partout il
reste encore les traces des violences de
la nuit
et petit à petit les carcasses sont
évacués si les rues ont retrouvé leur
calme
certains habitants ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude si je sors plus inquiet ce
soir il est posé c'est possible voilà à
quoi ressemblait clichy sous bois hier
soir des feux de voitures aux quatre
coins de la ville des bâtiments
administratifs pris pour cible jusqu'à 3
heures du matin des dizaines de casseurs
ont tout détruit sur leur passage et
jouer au chat et à la souris avec les
forces de l'ordre ce qui a déclenché
cette violence c'est la mort de deux
mineurs électrocuté alors qu'ils
s'étaient réfugiés dans ce local ddf
après avoir escaladé le mur plusieurs
adolescents présents hier soir affirme
que les policiers poursuivaient les
victimes
ils étaient quatre je lui départi de son
côté et les trois autres sont partis de
leur côté et il a bien vu que la police
était derrière les 3 et mont lâchez moi
pour les loger c'est lui parce qu'il
était tout seul ils sont partis vers les
3e version démentie par la police la
justice et le ministre de l'intérieur
ces jeunes essayait d'échapper à la
police mais il n'était pas à ce moment
là d'après ce qui m'est indiqué dans le
rapport écrit j'ai reçues il n'était pas
à ce moment-là poursuivi physiquement
par la police même s'il essayait de se
cacher la police des polices va tout de
même enquêté c'est ce qu'a appris le
maire de clichy après une table ronde au
ministère de l'intérieur cet après midi
au pied des immeubles du chêne pointu
l'imam a rassemblé les habitants pour
lancer des appels au cas comme toutes
les associations du quartier
il souhaite que la marche en hommage aux
deux victimes demain matin se déroule
sans incident
des scènes d'émeutes hier donc qui ont
terriblement gênées l'intervention des
pompiers qui ont été eux mêmes la cible
des violences et 190 policiers présents
sur place n'ont pas pu empêcher les
échauffourées et la brigade des sapeurs
pompiers a dû appliquer son propre plan
de sécurité explications loïc de la
mornais lors pâture aux écarts au tricot
ses vitres éclatées des projectiles
divers
ces impacts des coups de barre à mine
voici l'état dans lequel certains
camions de pompiers sont ressortis hier
soir des rues de clichy sous bois on
veut absolument faire comprendre aux
jeunes qui nous agressent que lorsqu'ils
nous agressent ils arrêtent les secours
ils arrêtent les engins qui vont porter
secours éventuellement à leur famille à
leurs proches
et ça il faut qu'ils le comprennent pas
ce qu il se pénalise et font du mal à
tout le monde
hier soir les pompiers ont dû mettre en
oeuvre le plan secours to blues urbain
un dispositif instauré en l'an 2000 est
pris en exemple sur les pompiers
d'irlande du nord habitué aux situations
tendues
il implique une organisation quasi
militaire et des renforts de police
important le phénomène d'agressions de
pompiers restent marginales mais des
actes isolés se sont multipliés ces
dernières années dans ces quartiers
difficiles
faut-il y voir une atteinte symbolique à
l'état pas six ans
c'est pas du tout un symbole de l'état
ils viennent et touche ce qui ce qui
vient de l'extérieur et qui arrivent
dans leur quartier et donc si c'est les
pompiers qui sont là et caillassent les
pompiers 6 et les policiers qui arrivent
ils peuvent également aussi l'a envoyé
des projectiles et si c'est une
infirmière qui vient ils peuvent lui
crever les pneus de sa voiture il n'y a
pas de démarche politique dans certains
cas dramatiques
l'agression est pourtant caractérisée
contre les pompiers comme ici en 2001 à
aulnay sous bois ou un véritable
guet-apens avait été tendu un camion de
pompiers appelés pour info incendie est
attaqué par un engin de chantier voler
ici les pompiers avaient dû affronter
des jets de boules de pétanque depuis
les toits et avait dû être protégé par
des centaines de crs est justement cette
autre mort dans des circonstances encore
plus violente toujours en seine saint
denis près pareil à épinay-sur-seine
cette fois un homme d'une cinquantaine
d'années a été littéralement battu à
mort dans un quartier dit sensible sous
les yeux de sa femme de ses enfants
réfugiés dans la voiture l'homme qui
travaillait dans une entreprise
spécialisée dans le mobilier urbain
photographier des réverbères il est mort
ce matin à l'hôpital jean françois cyr
et et florence ya un an dont tout s'est
passé très vite
il était 16 heures hier dans cette cité
d'epinay sur seine un homme de 56 ans
accompagné de sa femme et de sa fille
prend des lampadaires en photo il est
commercial il prépare un album pour sa
société de mobilier urbain soudain trois
ou quatre hommes se jettent sur lui lui
dérobe son appareil l'homme se rebelle
il est roué de coups devant sa fille et
son épouse les agresseurs s'enfuient
quelques secondes plus tard le
commercial est mort ce matin à l'hôpital
delafontaine de saint-denis
des témoins oculaires il y en a eu
plusieurs
mais par leur ont-ils aux enquêteurs
rien n'est moins sûr face à notre caméra
il préfère rester évasif par peur des
représailles regard soir hommage était à
la caisse et comme c'est la période de
ramadan
il ya beaucoup de mots non j'ai pas
grand chose mais les enquêteurs ont tout
de même quelques atouts la mairie
d'epinay sur seine à douter une partie
de la commune de caméras de
vidéosurveillance et donc nous espérons
que les enquêteurs vont pouvoir
exploiter les caméras de vidéo
surveillance présentes dans le quartier
au moment de l'agression
seul problème les images serait de
mauvaise qualité
c'est la brigade criminelle de paris qui
est chargée de l'enquêté
comme toujours avec ce type d'agression
collective l'identification des auteurs
sera très difficile le prix du gaz va
augmenter en france mais de façon
progressive sur les cinq prochains mois
la hausse sera limitée à 3,8 pour cent
sur l'année est en moyenne de gaz
augmentera tout de même 2 6%
explications de ces système à deux
vitesses avec vincent fourcade
le gouvernement a donné son accord et
dès mardi gaz de france relèvera ses
tarifs de 12% du donnant-donnant car en
échange gdf a dû faire un geste
commercial envers ses usagers pour
amortir cette nouvelle hausse
c'est le présent et gaz de france a
proposé une baisse de 45% de la bonne
mort pour l'ensemble des foyers français
dont qui se chauffent au gaz - 45 % sur
le prix de l'abonnement pendant cinq
mois soit une baisse totale de 22 euros
pour les 7 millions de foyers français
qui se chauffent au gaz selon gdf cette
diminution ponctuelle de l'abonnement
pourrait même faire baisser la facture
totale pour un logement de moins de 100
mètres carrés
mais ce coup de pouce ne durera qu'un
temps et disparaîtra avec l'hiver car
cette remise ne sera accordée que de
novembre à mars 2006 le gaz n'augmentera
alors que de 3,8 pour cent mais il ne
s'agit là que d'une moyenne y en a qui
payeront moins calade qui payons un peu
plus et au total il y aura de toute
façon un plafond à 8% une hausse maximum
de 8 % au lieu de 12 pour les
associations de consommateurs c'est
encore trop car le prix du gaz ne cesse
de grimper
cette hausse qu on nous qualifie moyenne
de 3,8 pour cent
s'ajoute à bien d'autres mais sur ces
deux dernières années on doit être à
plus de 16% de dos ou moyenne et le prix
du gaz devrait encore bondir dès que la
ristourne de gdf prendra fin la hausse
de 12 % s'appliquera alors totalement le
chômage recule en france pour le sixième
mois consécutif -0 9% en septembre des
chiffres dont se sont félicité
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
dominique de villepin et le ministre de
la cohésion sociale le jean louis borloo
étaient tous deux en visite à dijon et
pour la première fois il semble bien que
l'on assiste à un re démarrage des
créations d'emplois dans le secteur
privé même si les dispositifs sociaux et
des départs en retraite contribuer à
faire baisser le nombre de chômeurs les
contrat nouvelle embauche joue
incontestablement dans cette
amélioration sans mais ils ont été
signés depuis le 1er septembre
destiné aux entreprises de moins de 20
salariés
le contrat nouvelle embauche débute par
une période d'essai de deux ans une
souplesse qui a déjà convaincu les
petits patrons séverine de bras et jean
francois monier
abdel 24 ans chauffeur-livreur céline 24
ans est comptable et cassis 26 ans
commercial
tous viennent de signer un cn un contrat
nouvelle embauche dans cette petite pm
pendant deux ans leur patron pour allait
licencier sans justification deux ans
d'incertitude on a du mal à avancer
parce que avec un c est ne vous allez
dans n'importe quelle banque ou demander
un crédit spécial prendre acception
accepte ou pas mais je crois quand on
cherche du travail depuis un bout de
temps et pas trop le choix crohn céline
elle n'a pas hésité à quitter un cdi
pour ce nouveau poste je pense que quand
on fait ses preuves et qu'on est un bon
élément on n'a pas avoir ce genre de
peurs moi c'est pour ça que ça ne fait
pas du tout cas en tout cas une chose
est sûre sans ce contrat plus souple le
patron n'aurait jamais embauché trois
nouveaux salariés en à peine deux mois
aujourd'hui
je peux lancer de nouveaux projets donc
géant j'empoche alors que ce n'était pas
une
c'était n'était pas nécessaire pour
l'entreprise d'embaucher
elle se développe et naturellement toute
seule là ça va donner un coup de pouce
s'ils voulaient à notre entreprise selon
le gouvernement cent mille contrat
nouvelle embauche auraient déjà été
signés une petite bouffée d'oxygène pour
l'emploi
même si une partie de ces cmu ne font
que remplacer des cdd depuis aujourd'hui
les français peuvent acheter des actions
odf avant la cotation en bourse qui aura
lieu le 21 novembre
pour l'heure il s'agit de mettre sur le
marché 15% du capital du groupe
opération qui sera assortie d'une
augmentation de capital de 7 milliards
d'euros
depuis plusieurs années déjà l'état
s'est progressivement désengagée de ces
grandes entreprises commerciales
françois bonnet et jean yves leblanc
l'affichette a été bricolé en urgence et
violée pendant que vous allez bien mais
cette fois c'est parti
l'ouverture du capital d'edf a débuté
c'est toujours une période assez courte
dans cette agence bancaire on est
persuadé que cette opération rencontrera
un grand succès auprès du public
edf est quand même une entreprise qui
1re nom en français et qui en naturel
ment nous appellent pour se renseigner
l'entrée en bourse d'edf pourrait
d'ailleurs marqué le renouveau en france
de l'actionnariat populaire avec plus de
3 millions d'acheteurs pour les titres
gaz de france cet été
on est finalement plus très loin des 3
millions 900 mille épargnants qui
s'étaient rués sur l'action france
télécom en 97
à l'époque il fallait pour les réunir
louez le palais omnisports de bercy
alors l'état restera t-il majoritaire
dans edf le gouvernement s'y est engagé
d'ailleurs la loi du 9 août 2004
l'obligent à rester propriétaire d'au
moins 70% du capital
mais ni les syndicats ni la gauche ne
croient que cette situation sera durable
je suis prêt à parier que comme ça a été
le cas pour d'autres entreprises comme
par exemple france télécom dans quelques
années dix ans par exemple
l'etat sera dans une position
minoritaire dans le capital de cette
entreprise
et il est vrai que lors des
privatisations passé même partiel comme
celle de france télécom
les promesses initiales à l'arrivée
france télécom restera une entreprise
largement publics n'ont pas empêché
ensuite l'étape de se dégager petit à
petit du capital il aura ainsi fallu
seulement sept ans pour que l'opérateur
historique de vienne privé et cinq ans à
peine pour l'ex compagnie nationale air
france
le rachat du néerlandais klm ayant même
réduit encore un peu plus la part de
l'état au total toutes les entreprises
publiques dont le capital a été ouvert
avant 2002 sont aujourd'hui privés mais
pour edf
l'enjeu est encore plus lourd le premier
électricien mondial dispose aussi du
premier parc européen de centrales
nucléaires et pour l'instant personne ne
souhaite que l'état en perdre le
contrôle à marseille 25e jour de grève
pour les transports en commun et
toujours pas de réquisition en dépit des
demandes persistantes du maire jean
claude gaudin
le gouvernement a préféré nommer un
médiateur dans ce conflit il s'agit du
spécialiste de droit social bernard
brunhes correspondance unique à rossi et
christophe laroque
des policiers pour éviter toute nouvelle
dégradation sur les autobus de
substitution et pour calmer les tensions
car au 25e jour de grève nombre de
marseillais en ont assez je passe mes
papiers à pietra que je cours je compte
sur les bus et les métros pour pour
pouvoir aller travailler voilà j'arrive
le grillage les terminaux là je risque
de faire ma place j'ai un corps j'ai
encore deux qui vont arriver dacquois
s'appelle tu partiras dix bateaux a
atteint 10% des bus de la rtm circulent
ainsi que les 50 autocars de
substitution
malgré la demande du maire de marseille
le préfet n'a pas jugé bon pour
l'instant de réquisitionner chauffeur et
matérielles ce pouvoir de réquisition du
préfet suppose que toutes les voies de
négociation et était auparavant et
empreinte de pré fall jusqu'au bout de
ces négociations
or les négociants n'a pas commencé le
maire de marseille n'a pas obtenu gain
de cause lundi le médiateur nommé par le
gouvernement entamera ses consultations
mais la discussion sur la gestion du
futur tramway risque de tourner court
délégation de service public elle a été
votée le 24 mars
elle a été votée par une assemblée issue
du suffrage universel et il n'est pas
question de le retirer
les traminots refuse toujours tout net
se montrer de laconnex sociétés privées
dans le tramway marseillais que le
tramway appartiennent à la régie que le
train ne soit pas donner au privé il n'y
a pas de négociation possible là-dessus
peau je pense pas qu est ce qui est le
propre du national action on attend les
employés de l'air calmes ont reconduit
le mouvement de grève à pauillac près de
bordeaux dans un oeuf en chocolat en
guise de gadgets un petit garçon à
trouver une aiguille de seringue
apparemment usagers la friandise
fabriqué en italie étaient garnies de
jouer venant de chine
tous les oeufs de cette marque ya tout
là ont été retirés de la vente
christelle marty et david bazié au
premier abord c e en chocolat ce sont de
simples friandises
à l'intérieur un jouet de surprise dont
raffolent les enfants mais d'il ya
quelques jours dans l'un d'entre eux un
jeune garçon trouve une seringue taché
de sang c'est dans ce supermarché de
pauillac en gironde que l'oeuf a été
acheté mais dès les faits connus
les lots de l'ensemble des supermarchés
du groupe ont été retirés des rayons
les clients ont été avertis de
l'incident une référence pour faire quoi
chez nous mais on est quand même
l'information consommateur et qu'on
ad'autres magasin de la même enseigne
qu'ils sont sont pas loin d'ici
mais qui peut plus vendre de ses yeux
c'est un fabricant qui est à l'étranger
donc il faut faire des enquêtes pour
remonter et voir si éventuellement il
sont pas commercialisés sous d'autres
marques
les clients qui auraient acheté des
oeufs en chocolat ya tout là de la
marque puma d'or sont invités à les
rapporter dans les supermarchés une
enquête est ouverte pour déterminer
l'origine de l'éguille retrouver à dijon
le service de médecine néonatale a été
fermée hier depuis plusieurs semaines
six enfants prématurés ont été infectées
par une en terro colite quatre de ses
enfants sont décédés il s'agissait de
grands prématurés faisons moins d'un
kilo très sensibles à ce type de
bactéries qui détruisent à paroi
intestinale
laurent dit nikola lisez les premières
ambulances ont commencé les transfert
dès cet après midi
direction les autres hôpitaux de la
région ce nourrisson sera peut être le
prochain à quitter le service
réanimation néonatale du chu de dijon
depuis la mi juin
4 prématuré accueilli ici sont décédées
des suites de la même maladie lente hero
call it nécrosante qui provoque une
destruction de la paroi intestinale chez
les grands prématurés en temps normal
seuls un ou deux cas sont détectés
chaque année dans cet hôpital
ça n'est pas une maladie contagieuse
dans sa forme habituelle on les observe
de façon on va dire sporadiques
ponctuelles et c'est justement le
caractère regrouper de plusieurs cas en
plus très sévère qui doit attirer
l'attention
en principe c'est une bactérie qui
provoque cette infection mais les
médecins qui ont constaté les symptômes
différents chez les enfants touchés
craignent que d'autres facteurs ne soit
en cause des virus par exemple
malgré les mesures d'hygiène
supplémentaires de nouveaux cas ont été
diagnostiqués ces derniers jours
l'hôpital a donc décidé de la fermeture
temporaire du service concerné pour un
nettoyage complet
on procède je dirais aux plus de
précautions possibles
rien ne dit que ce soit un problème lié
aux locaux mais comme rien ne le dit pas
non plus et bien on préfère procéder de
cette de cette façon là en tout une
cinquantaine de nourrissons devrait être
déplacée pour l'occasion les transferts
devrait donc se poursuivre dans les
prochains jours pas de grippe a vient en
revanche pour les trois touristes
français originaire de l'île de la
réunion soupçonné d'avoir était infectée
lors d'un voyage en thaïlande
après examens et tests les trois grippés
ont pu rentrer chez eux en martinique
demain seront rapatriés les 145
dépouilles des victimes de l'accident
d'avion de la west caribbean au
venezuela
toutes les familles se préparent pour
ses obsèques qui ont dieu plus de deux
mois après le drame et alors qu'on ne
connaît toujours pas les circonstances
exactes de l'accident
yasmina farber et franck crise et
saint-esprit est une commune de 8000
âmes 43 se sont envolés le 16 août
dernier dans le cimetière
on prépare leur retour leur tombe
l'uci va enterrer sa nièce gerty avait
25 ans elle reposera dans le caveau
familial
j'ai le souvenir de ma nièce le joue là
son mariage mariage qu'elle est partie
il a fallu identifier les 160 victimes
dont 152 martiniquais un travail
complexe
seule une dizaine de corps étaient
restés intacts pour les autres
trente-quatre personnes d'un laboratoire
de bordeaux ont analysé les empreintes
génétiques en priorité prendre les
corses étaient la première urgence de
l'enquète à fort de france
deux juges sont chargées du dossier
albert cantinolle et véronique forge
sont plutôt discrets mais ils ont
accepté de nous recevoir
les boîtes noires ont livré un premier
indice le pilote parle de deux réacteurs
éteints mais les magistrats restent
extrêmement prudents
une phase de lecture ensuite de décodage
et puis ensuite de mise en mise en
concordance avec des experts et pilotes
intelligible et choisit les deux juges
parts la semaine prochaine au venezuela
et en colombie
les moteurs de l'avion vont être
expertisés mail enquête ne s'arrête pas
là à travailler sur cette fois-ci de
l'avion lui-même c'est-à-dire la
maintenance l'équipage est ce qu'ils ont
été formés et c'est ce qu'ils avaient
toutes les qualités pour la compagnie
aérienne le suivi de l'avion
les résultats de l'enquêté ne sont pas
pour l'immédiat et les familles s'y
prépare mais pour l'instant leur
priorité c'est d'enterrer leurs disparus
après soixante quinze jours n'attente
circulation chargée sur les routes de
france ce week-end à partir de ce soir
dans le sens des départs et mercredi
dans le sens des retours ce long week
end de la toussaint traditionnellement
meurtrier mobilise les forces de police
et de gendarmerie
et comme chacun sait la tactique du
gendarme c'est d'être toujours là où on
ne l'attend pas ils vont marcher et
olivier combe
à bord du fourgon funéraire de corps
sans vie
ceux de deux motards entrés en collision
8h ce matin aux portes de toulouse
commence pour les gendarmes le week-end
le plus noir de l'année
c'est l'un des week-ends les plus
dangereux vous avez plusieurs week-ends
qui sont ciblés de toi le week end de
pâques le week-end de la pentecôte ou
week-end de la toussaint
alors pour le seul département de la
haute garonne 400 hommes mobilisés tous
affectés à la sécurité du trafic
alors vous avez 0 23 mg d'alcool par
litre d'air expiré
d'accord le taux maximal autorisé ces
0,25 mg par litre d'air expiré
vous êtes limite ça arrive assez
régulièrement les gens ne sachant pas à
quoi ça va se tenir ne sachant pas
combien consommée par rapport aux taux
autorisés fonds d'aidé fois quelques
excès contrôle intensif durant les
périodes à risque les automobilistes
semblent comprendre il faut qu'il y ait
plus de contrôle il faut que je sois
plus sévères comme ça ira moins
d'accidents moins de morts routes
nationales autoroutes
objectif être vu car la peur du képi
fait ralentir mais il ya aussi les
opérations plus discrète
exemple cette voiture banalisée c'est un
radar automatique embarqué très mobiles
et très pratique puisque nous déplaçons
plusieurs endroits plusieurs points avec
cet appareil
ce week-end sur les routes de haute
garonne
les gendarmes seront pas fois quatre
fois plus nombreux qu'à l'accoutumée
une raison supplémentaire d'être prudent
et dans le val-de-marne la sécurité
routière a décidé de sensibiliser les
jeunes aux risques de la conduite sans
permis
il faut dire que depuis deux ans ce type
d'infraction augmenté de 40%
l'objectif aujourd'hui formé au lieu de
réprimer valérie fournis ou emmanuel
maurel
la visite n'est pas banal deux jeunes
délinquants de la route tous mineurs
offert d'un dispositif policier
autoroutier ici ils vont être confrontés
à la dure réalité du terrain c'est le
but de cette formation très particulière
la réparation pénale sur l'accident
toute sécurité parce que bien sûr sinon
cela arrive dessus et qu'il ya une
circulation fluide on va se mettre en
danger mais on leur met en danger les
usagers qui sont derrière nous quant à
bien pour nautique de la théorie à la
pratique il est reçu un accident vient
d'avoir lieu
c'est bien ça un motard vient de
percuter une voiture
le groupe est dépêchée sur les lieux de
l'accident de quoi faire réfléchir ces
jeunes qui ont tous commis le délit de
conduire sans permis car pour eux
c'était soit la prison soit cette
formation
stubb a déjà sonné le diplôme on pourra
faire les premiers sons à aurait pu nous
arriver à un monde nous voit
c'est vrai que ça nous fait prendre
conscience des risques ya le principe du
stage de réparation pénale c'est
justement de leur faire voir un petit
peu tous les principes de sécurité
routière et leur fait une prise de
conscience en les armant son terrain
comme ici effectivement les amenant sur
l'accident pour qu'il voit vraiment le
travail des secours le travail de la
police
oui mais la prise de conscience passe
aussi par le visionnage des images chocs
mais bien réel d'accidents sur place et
qu'on est arrivé elle est encore vivante
c'est une personne que nous on vous voit
mourir sont moins qu'en commettaient des
infractions au code de la route
vous respectez pas des règles de
sécurité ne nous demandez pas surtout
pas nous détruire des gens des jeunes
savaient se comprenait pas les choses
donc je commence à frapper de l'agepi le
stage que j'y vais ça commence à bien
réfléchir
ça m'a aidé à façonner permis de gens
apprendre à être citoyen responsable de
ses actes c'est tout l'enjeu de la
réparation pénale
la répression par l'éducation les
filières terroristes internationales
ont-elles fourni en france des missiles
sol air provenant de la tchétchénie
si ce casseur notre confrère le figaro
dans son édition de ce matin une
information sur laquelle la justice
française reste très prudente
les islamistes radicaux français sont
sous haute surveillance philippe
visseyrias publiée en une du journal le
figaro
la nouvelle a de quoi faire peur on y
apprend que des islamistes français
s'apprête à attaquer des avions de ligne
sur le sol français avec deux lances
missiles achetés auprès de la mafia
tchétchène un scénario terrifiant
selon l'article cette menace aurait été
identifié par le juge antiterroriste
jean louis bruguière qui enquêtent sur
des réseaux de djihadiste français formé
en tchétchénie contacté ce matin jean
louis bruguière n'a voulu faire aucun
commentaire
depuis d'autres sources judiciaires ont
mis en doute l'existence d'une telle
menace
selon elle rien ne prouve que ces deux
lances missiles se trouve sur le sol
français ni même qu'ils existent car il
se pourrait bien que cette menace
d'attentât n'était qu'un projet parmi
d'autres projets évoqués par un
islamiste jordanien emprisonné à amman
et interrogés par les services secrets
jordaniens et non par des enquêteurs
français
cet ancien responsable du
contre-espionnage lui reste perplexe
j'ignore totalement s'il existe en
france ce type de missile dans les
périodes de 2002 ce type d'information
ne circulait pas 2002 c'est
l'arrestation en banlieue parisienne
deux jeunes français de retour de
tchétchénie dans cette enquête les
policiers disposent de témoignages
évoquant des projets d'attentats
chimiques à paris les témoignages mais
peu d'éléments matériels
un dossier dont l'instruction se termine
le procès devrait avoir lieu en mars
2006 en iran manifestations contre
israël l appel du président ultra
conservateur nouvellement élu et qui
était lui même en tête de cortège une
immense foule s'est répandue dans les
rues de téhéran bertrand cocq mort à
israël
à bas l'amérique ils sont des dizaines
de milliers d'iraniens toutes
générations confondues à reprendre ce
matin les déclarations enflammées de
leur président c'est un rituel instauré
par l'ayatollah khomeiny le fondateur de
la république islamique
la journée anti sioniste annuel sorte de
carnaval macabre où défilent candidats
au martyre et foule galvanisée des
effigies de bush et sharon sont immolés
le drapeau israélien piétiner en dépit
de l'indignation suscitée par ses propos
mahmoud ahmadinedjad persiste dans son
appel à rayer israël de la carte
le président ultraconservateur qui s'est
offert un bain de foule avant d'affirmer
mémos sont les mots exacts du peuple
iranien reste que le régime où les durs
ont repris l'aventage depuis six mois a
paru surpris par les réactions de la
communauté internationale à téhéran des
responsables parlent de manipulation
médiatique
arguant que la position de l'iran sur la
palestine n'a pas varié depuis 25 ans
quant à la maison blanche un proche
collaborateur du vice-président
américain dick cheney démissionne lewis
libby a été mise en examen pour entrave
à la justice parjure et faux témoignage
il avait divulgué le nom d'une femme
agent secret de la cia pour faire taire
les critiques de certains de ses proches
sera guerre en irak mais révélé le nom
d'un agent secret est un crime fédéral
aux états unis la démission de lewis ce
débit fragilise toute l'administration
bush
tennis trois français disputeront les
demi finales du tournoi de lyon gaël
monfils a battu son compatriote marc
gicquel dans le premier quart icap 1
et puis sébastien grosjean s'est imposé
face au belge olivier rochus en deux
sets 6-3 7-6
quant à fabrice santoro il a battu
l'américain vince spadea sébastien
grosjean également fils s'affronteront
donc en demi finale
dans le pas de calais le site du câble
en est victime de son succès mérité une
importante restauration après la pointe
du raz et le mont saint michel c'est
autour des célèbres falaises du nord de
la france qui font face à l'angleterre
de retrouver un aspect un peu sauvage
frais de réunions et patrick bertrand
c'est un roc c'est un cap presque une
péninsule à plus de 150 mètres au dessus
des flots le cap blanc nez est une
triple curiosité géographique falaises
calcaires la plus au nord de france elle
fait aussi face aux côtes anglaises et
marque le passage des eaux de la manche
à celle de la mer du nord
le problème c'est que chaque dimanche
après midi voici à quoi ressemble la
route qui borde le site
l'embouteillage des garanties au point
que le conseil général a dû depuis la
rentrée condamner les 300 derniers
mètres qui permettait jusque là aux
voitures d'arriver directement sur le
rocher tout au bord de la famine
nous avons voulu intervenir
c'est à dire que nous avons voulu
redonner entièrement ce site à la nature
refaire des chemins naturel et que les
gens puissent profiter du paysage et de
l'environnement de façon intéressante
il n'y a pas plus tard qu'un mois il y
avait encore 500 voitures sur le site
derrière moi avec trois ou quatre
baraque à frites des marchands de glace
et tout ça dans un vacarme de groupes
électrogènes et de bruits de voitures là
a dit m de la falaise à 10 m de la
falaise tout à fait
recouvert de terre l'ancien parking sera
bientôt revégétaliser pour se fondre
dans le paysage
comme c'était le cas autrefois les
sentiers piétons seront également créées
pour éviter que les touristes ne
s'éparpillent sur tout le site ou leur
passage creuse des ravins et détruit la
flore des touristes qui apprécient très
diversement d'avoir désormais à faire à
pied
les quelques hectomètres
qui les sépare de la départementale
certaines personnes auront du mal à
monter parce que ça s'arrête pas et
handicapées voulait dire les personnes
âgées les personnes plus âgées
je pense que c'est très bien parce que
si tout le monde pourra venir parce
qu'autrement
mais par qui n'était bloqué son peut
dire par des voitures ventouses et les
campings bantous également tout des
primes car les combines car oui à partir
du moment où il ya des halles est fait
pour les poussettes qui soit pratique ça
gêne en rien à terme le deuxième parking
situé au pied de la falaise sera lui
aussi supprimé
il faudra donc stationner dans les
villages ou dans l'un des parkings
éloignées qui seront bientôt aménagé
pour les 1 à 2 millions de visiteurs
annuels
la meilleure façon de marcher jusqu'à la
plage sera donc à nouveau de mettre un
pied devant l'autre
à moins qu'ils ne préfèrent désormais
arriver directement par la mer à bord de
véhicules certes moins confortable mais
tout à fait écologique
à paris le musée picasso célèbre ses 20
ans en honorant le peintre et le dessin
facette méconnue de cet artiste mais qui
permet de découvrir beaucoup de petits
secrets cachés dans les célèbres
tableaux du peintre espagnol michel
bonté ce n'est plus entré dans une
exposition sur les dessins de picasso
c'est comme entrer un peu par effraction
dans l'esprit d'un génie au travail
tenté de pénétrer les mystères de
somalie
tenter de suivre la main la main qui
fait le dessin et le dessin c'est bien
tous les jours pour picasso
le dessin raconte son chemin
l'évolution jour après jour de ses
passions
c'est très précieux on voit les
changements des hésitations les doutes
et puis tout d'un coup la certitude
qu'ils apparaissent et passionnant
passionnant de démêler un peu la pelote
de laine inextricable de son trait qui
cherchent et au milieu du chaos n'est
toujours une forme l'endroit de son
génie picasso voit tout et le met à sa
sauce sa collection de cartes postales
africaine et comme un trousseau de
plaider pour ouvrir mi l'énigme picasso
l'africain et voilà la solution des bras
levés position qui paraît cette
énigmatique et personnage central des
demoiselles d'avignon
la frite bien sûr que tu cruche les
femmes indigènes qui se trouve encore
aujourd'hui dans ses archives
photographiques sont probablement l'une
des clés sur un tacle ou une femme
accroupie les jambes écartées
encore une puis encore une picasso ne
cherche pas il trouve et il signe de la
pointe du pinceau d'un taureau qui veut
dire picasso
hé hé
et
il s'appelle rafael mais lui une chance
et c'est déjà une valeur sûre du métier
à 30 ans il sort son troisième album et
sera pour trois jours à l'olympia
olivier dénoue d'sa jean-marc il y a
deux ans il sillonnait les routes de
france au monospace aujourd'hui raphaël
repart en tournée mais dans un puce à
double étage version grand luxe
c'est une maison roulante mais le petit
monospace vv il était super si je n'ai
pas beaucoup
rafa est choyé par sa maison de disques
pas étonnant l'artiste est une mine d'or
des concerts qui font salle comble et un
troisième album vendu en moins de six
mois à six cent mille exemplaires
ce que j'en ai les larmes aux yeux
comment maintien n'est plus un sens
si le monde
oui
j'aime son côté un peu du très jeune un
petit plus qui raconte ça c'est
politique j'aime bien j'ai bien studio 1
moi quand je sors d'un de studio j'ai un
moment un peu déprimé c'est à dire c'est
une des moments de découragement complet
au japon où tout est nul et c'est
dommage c'est que voilà et puis un
moment on sait plus du tout
j'ai l'avenir dans le vent
je vends
auteur compositeur interprète raphaël
rend hommage à patrick daher évoque les
inégalités chante le simple bonheur
d'être en vie pour moi la musique
c'était un truc tellement fort un sac
pour transformer l'ennui ça peut
transformer la la tristesse est
extrêmement plein d'espérance c'est un
truc qui embellit le quotidien comment
c'est une belle chanson que c'est un
truc qui est simple mais pas vulgaire
on y passe
ce conte animé
en 2002 il faisait la première partie de
son idole david bowie à l'olympia le lin
piao raphaël se produira trois soirs la
semaine prochaine bien sûr tout est
complexe si ce terme et ce journal je
vous remercie de votre attention c'est à
météo patrice drevet suivi des points
groupe valérie maurice 20h50 soirée
voilà avec pj 1h10 jaune de la nuit
laurence piquet j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver dès demain 13h excellente
centrale assure françois rey source